[Musique]
diagonale de retour dans ce groupe tony
thorium de cannes pour la deuxième
partie des demi-finales des quarts de
finale avec la partie stéphane kasparov
tkatchev castor quatre chefs avec un
enjeu simple le vainqueur est qualifié
et en cas de match nul et devront
disputer des matchs de départage ce soir
à 22h à noter que quatre chefs a fait
une très belle première partie il a tenu
le choc face à kasparov
il a même fait mieux que ça puisqu'il a
inquiété garry kasparov vienne avait
failli essayer de le battre
enfin il a essayé de le battre en tout
cas il a failli y arriver mais ensuite
kasparov s'est retrouvé un petit peu
mieux et vladislav à calmer le jeu il a
calmé le jeu et il a fait nul donc là il
va voir les noirs à noter que gary est
un boucher quand ils allaient blanc il
n'est pas là pour rigoler on le sait
c'est vrai oui ça va être dur pour
quatre chefs savoir à ce qu'il va
réussir à tenir avec les noirs voire
même inquiété
karine kasparov s'est enfin tout l'enjeu
de cette partie à noter que kasparov a
pas perdu deux parties avec les blancs
depuis très longtemps
et oui tout à fait c'est vrai quel sport
fait gris blanc il est vraiment
phénoménal
esquennoy aussi d'ailleurs mais en fait
ça va pas être facile pour vlad je pense
que son plan c'est de tenir dans cette
partie s'ils arrivent à faire nul il
aura les beats se départagent et c'est
sa spécialité
kasparov évidemment est très fort en
beats mais en tout cas si quelqu'un peut
l'inquiéter c'est bien ben ladislav
quatre chefs et voilà effectivement donc
là nous voyons pour l'instant la scène
il va bientôt y avoir la présentation
des joueurs et dans quelques petites
minutes
nous allons commencer les directs oui
mais fameux direct
les parties en direct alors que la voilà
deux commentateurs en kényane où plein
sur les commentateurs ans mais
maintenant voyons c'est équipé avec des
casques ce qui nous permet donc d'être
lié directement au réalisateur donc donc
voilà on peut vous montrer des éléments
ici à l'ordinateur qui nous permet de
générer le signal est donc ça va bientôt
commencer
donc on vous invite à regarder un petit
peu la salle voilà la salle
vue de côté et bientôt garry kasparov va
faire son entrée sur scène il y a
également etienne bacrot contre
viellevigne bas relief mais ça paraît
compromis pour le français très
compromis puisqu'il a perdu avec les
blancs il faut il faut absolument qu'ils
essaient de gagner avec les noirs c'est
quasiment de tâches impossibles contre
bas reliefs qui est un joueur
extrêmement solide et qui on l'a vu hier
aussi est très fort avec les noirs
puisqu'il aguila ganic entre etienne
bacrot mais avait aussi gagné contre
choël lautier avec les petits ce noir
bar y avait exactement force qui avait
d'ailleurs poussé loti au départage et a
causé sa perte puisque au départage il
n'a pas su s'en sortir
c'est vrai que c'est très très difficile
donc etienne bacrot là ils allaient
nouari l'objet de gagner contre eux j'ai
vieilli bas relief
ça paraît extrêmement difficile puisque
bas relief est un joueur d'expérience un
joueur qui ne laisse pas passer sa proie
facilement et donc ça va pas être facile
pour le jeune français mais le match du
jour c'est quand même évidemment
kasparov contre quatre chefs
c'est le premier quart de finale de
garry kasparov et tout de suite il est
inquiété puisqu'il n'arrive pas à passer
pour cette première partie donc il va
devoir essayer de gagner avec les blancs
sinon il est poussé au bide c'est là
tout devient possible stephan bitz en
glisse tout à fait possible lagaf est
vite arrivé on l'a vu on l'a vu hier
avec earl beauty qui a perdu en douze
coups contre jeudi paul garret oui il
s'est fait prendre la dame
joël lautier il a pris une tournure un
peu trop confiants il s'est fait
enfermer la dame
ce qui a provoqué son abandon
voilà vous voyez les joueurs qui sont en
train de s'installer sur scène voilà
etienne bacrot se faire la main 2 il y
brille avec le sourire il est content
avec deux sauts rien il sait que le
public et pour lui et il joue là-dessus
ladislav ira kasparov
il sait que le public est contre lui et
donc il ne joue pas du tout dessus
c'est vrai ça va être la partie du
moment garry kasparov contre vladislav
tkachiev voilà motivé garry kasparov
il faut qu'ils gagnent voilà on voit
beaucoup de gens sur le public beaucoup
de journalistes
c'est la grand maman de cette coupe du
monde
vladislav tkachiev contre garry kasparov
failli se déboutonnent la chemise garry
kasparov
maintenant il commence par ça puisqu'on
semi-rapide déjà pas trop le temps de le
faire pendant la partie
alalalala alors que les journalistes
sont là comme débouche sur le miel a
filmé ce grand moment et on voit que
vlad aime bien prêté leur visage aux
journalistes c'est à dire que vlad a la
capacité à prendre la lumière
ouais c'est il est toujours vers la
lumière
on voit eric morel arbitre de cette
rencontre et ils ces partis à la casse
par un flux à imposer de vire les
journées ça y est ça commence
c'est parti e4 e5 joué par vladislav
kovalev 3 4 et 6 ça va être une
espagnole c'est sûr voilà ça y est c'est
fait fouquet 5 de kasparov à 6 x 4 qui
la permet pas d'avoir un de kramnik la
berlinoise que si ce petit rock fou
c'est simple comme bonjour c'est fossati
joola tour eu des 5
ça va très vite four b3 et petit rock
tout ça c'est très classique espoir de
rejouer à quatre ils n'aiment pas le
gambit marshall voilà c'est fait il n'a
fait la foulée c'est tout trouvé huit
sont les deux coups dans cette position
l'esclavagé ou fou mais cette théorie
c'est fait des trois par kasparov
ça chauffe ça chauffe ça va très très
vite en ce début de partie et tout ça
c'est très connu vladislav connaît bien
il a sans doute une préparation groupe
des six les spurs jouent cavalli c3
k&b des dunks alley les [ __ ] 2 il joue le
comédien de d2 c'est un développement
plus rampant il veut le mettre en f1
puis en e3 et fin puis cavaliers à 3
c'est exactement ce qu'il a joués n'ya
pas longtemps gary kasparov donc ça ne
peut pas surprendre
vladislav ladislav voilà il sait ce
qu'il va faire vladislav inédit qui
recalcule bientôt 8.8 il répète une
partie qu'il a joué récemment kasparov
bas et tout à fait sûrs à 100 par
bouquet sport cavaliers fin voilà ça y
est c'est une partie avec hands est
sûrement ou à linares c'est une partie
de linares je ne sais plus contre qui
j'ai un trou fou h 6 h 6,7 contre peter
l'écho et là on met recueillir 3 c'est
ça c'est la partie kopitar et qu il va
jouer cavalier ou 3 c sur food est de
fous des deux c'est le développement
qu'il avait utilisé contre peter l'écho
c'est un coup maintenant c'est une
nouveauté ils empêchent les cahiers des
leurs à 5
et ça devrait plonger pladys lave dans
une réflexion ici normalement il connaît
forcément cette partie bénisse la vie
oui mais seulement de ces nouveaux
normalement c'est qu'elle vit à troyes
le coup stéphane qui avait été utilisé
la dernière fois fou des deux c'est une
tentative d'amélioration de garry
kasparov fois huit jeux ladislav ne se
laisse pas ces spams pression intoxiqué
et l'acajou kasparov de jouer tempo il a
joué ses 4
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est un
nouveau concept de galerie sparrow car
oui c'est un nouveau concept au in ça
c'est pas du tout alors sûr c'est une
réparation faite pour cette partie alors
là le pion de bessengue de vladislav est
attaqué il va devoir bouger très
vraisemblablement peut-être soit avancée
soit prendre quelque part c'est les deux
possibilités pour vlad également on voit
l'inconvénient de secousses et 4 c'est
que la case des cadres devient faible
stéphane puisqu'il ya aucun pion qui
peut revenir d'allemagne pour le qui
peut revenir le contrôle est donc un
cavalier pourra s'y installer plus tard
voilà une fois que le cavaliere 3 aura
bougé par exemple oui si le cac edf 3 à
noter quand même que cette ouverture est
connu pour être complexe parce qu'aucun
pions et
une pièce non été échangés exactement
c'est ce qu'on appelle la torture
espagnol ça donne une partie très très
positionnelle vingt dix la blague est
très concentré très concentré stéphane
on peut le voir sur cette image
wen là il est vraiment à fond c'est
clair pour le canada quel qu'est ce que
c'est que son coût c4
un coup curieux on va peut-être dire
quelques mots sur cette position
stéphane oui alors peut-être le coup b5
b4 est envisageable
donc là il va falloir montrer ça nous
coûte beesan b4 qui a l'air d'être a
priori le plus solide
ouais pour fermer un peu pour jouer à
saint caprais
il veut contrôler le fou de cazaux cases
noires contre ce foot et 2 mais
également contre le fouquet's blanche
surtout stéphane puisqu'il serait en
mesure et par ses propres pions oui on
voit ici se fout des trois qui peut être
amenée à se faire enfermer donc ici ça a
pas l'air super ce que fait kasparov
mais en tout cas ça a le mérite d'être
surprenant et en partie rapide c'est
important de prendre tout de suite
l'initiative
oui notamment longtemps et est donc au
niveau de la préparation de l'ouverture
ça surprend l'autre réfléchi voilà et la
preuve est que notre espace est utilisée
que 30 secondes contre presque quatre
minutes maintenant quatre chefs mais oui
vladislav qui joue l'échiquier il a pris
en c4 ils apprennent ces cartes il a
pris dans ses 4 un choix tout à fait
responsable de vladislav il faut le voir
tu reprends c4 et la kasparov a repris
avec le fou le foot kasparov devient
donc puissant stéphane quand il tape sur
9,7 fin août et voilà le roi est
derrière donc ça fait une puissance de
feu une artillerie
est ce que de ketchup va jouer à 5 dans
cette position pour bloquer la vente
possible kasparov
avec l'option b c'est tout à fait
possible
qu'est-ce qu'il peut jouer d'autres
puisque on voit que le cavalier de garry
kasparov et prêts à ressortir
ah là là ça c'est intéressant le plan
que nous avions la très très intéressant
kasparov goûter sur la table on le voit
assez il a joué il ajoute tourbe et 8
ladislav 1 dans un premier temps fanny
cela fâche ou est tombé huit et kasparov
a répliqué quasiment tempo par fous ces
3 français 3 il veut jouer d3 d4
kasparov et ouvrir complètement la
position pensée de fou
la paire de faux ici la paire de fou qui
est très très forte
il veut ouvrir peut-être avec des quatre
et on doit faire 10 lave là sur sa
chaise avec la chaise pencher en arrière
stefan wey il un équilibre la viande et
qu'il pourra qui tombent assez instable
là on voit ça c'est les pieds de
kasparov je pense
voilà on voit la chemise bleue de
kasparov
elle avait les nerveux garry kasparov il
est nerveux et vladislav idée bien
repris en arrière qu'est ce qui se passe
dans cette partie après fou c3 et bien
c'est un plat de joanne k stores vont
jouer des quatre donc ces femmes une
proposition pour les noirs une
proposition pour les noirs c'est ce
qu'il nous faut ici
eh bien on pourrait jouer je sais pas
c'est pas évident pas évident évident il
faut replacer une pièce il faut replacer
une pièce c'est sûr peut-être qu'à
valider cette cover 600 contre des 4l
c'est là quelque pour l'instant des
quatre est impossible puisque si les
blancs jouent des 4 évidemment il y
aurait prise en d4
donc on va regarder cette variante sur
des 4 ici nous regarde c'est ce coup là
il y aurait prise en d4 et ensuite le
cavalier f6 prendrait dans l occase sur
la case de 4 puisque le pion aux quatre
se retrouveront aux prises par les deux
pièces donc pour l'instant des cartes
n'est pas une menace la menace
positionnelle de garry kasparov ses
cavaliers aux 3/8 5
vraisemblablement cette thématique dans
l'espagnol ouais ce cavalier deviennent
très fort au f5 qu'il faudrait que vlad
se prémunissent contre ça qu'est ce
qu'il va faire bien entendu là et c'est
inquiétant
stéphane puisque vladislav n'a que 19
minutes restantes contre 24 à kasparov
il a déjà 100 milles de retard
oui ça fait beaucoup ça commence à être
un petit peu dérangeant sarah est ce que
jouer pour plus tard dans la partie
il faut pas comme ladislav se laisse
endormir c'est vrai à l'époque marina
les réflexions là il faut vraiment
savoir gérer son temps il s'est fait
surprendre à l'ouverture de kasparov la
maladie cela fait il réfléchit un peu
trop là c'est pas bon c'est pas bon il
va falloir qu'il accélère le rythme et
le problème c'est que si commencé à
accélérer quand ça va devenir plus
compliqué l'apab la position est déjà
assez complexe mais s'il devait encore
plus compliqué en accélérant risque
faire des gaffes
c'est le problème dans la des parties
rapides on voit vladislav l' arrêt il a
choisi m coup il a joué qu'est-ce qu'il
a joué pour qui la joue et camélia en 17
noms cavalier a que ça qui audio 7
il veut replacer son carillon g6 bla
l'islam et éventuellement jouer le coup
c'est cette c5 est resté fan alors que
l'ordinateur mentionne le couffo prend
au sein qui fou prend 1,5 possible fou
promesses en l'air trois pions
complètement incroyable ça récupère
trois pions c'est un coup incroyable ça
serait le coup qui fait le cas où ça si
ça marche on va vous montrer c'est du
virtuel pour l'instant fou prend tient
aux cinq pions prend fou qu'avaient les
pensions et le curé vii est perdu et on
voit qu'elle est de pièces attaque
l'option eps vii qui est perdue ici
l'ordinateur propose la défense suivante
cavadee en d5 qui a l'air très très très
bizarre
en fait c'est un sacrifice de pions la
pression tant dessin qui vient reprend
avec lecavalier
d'où le fou ou le fou au choix peut-être
le fou l'oeuf ou plutôt le fou plutôt de
vous est donc ici c'est une position
extrêmement complexe donc à leur endroit
hors montre cette position cavaliers
c'est bien d'être le parent vlad le coup
critique
c'est fou prend pion aux 5 pour ses
stars au sacrifice de kasparov possible
maintenant dans cette position avec fou
prend pion aux 5 et 6 non vladislav va
mettre son cavalier ou g6 et il aura une
position très jouable il peut même
envisager après de jouer c'est cette c5
avec plutôt une belle position
je pense que vlad n'a pas être inquiet
il n'a pas être inquiet dans cette
position quand même un assez satisfait
de son ouverture vladislav com alors
est-ce que la dce la menace pas de jouer
des cinq as lors des 5e stephan s'est un
peu trop chaud le pion aux 5 et
deviendra montréal faible alors c'est
dangereux ce coup là qu'il a joués
blaney cavalli ou sept
la cie kasparov répliques parfois prend
2,5 après avoir calculé on peut dire que
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle ça serait
pas une bonne nouvelle mais je crois que
néanmoins que la position de platts
auraient tout à fait bonnes
faut produire 5 n'ayant pas l'air d'être
un coup extrêmement fort
donc ici qu'est ce qu'on peut dire eh
bien on peut dire on peut dire que
kasparov réfléchit on le voilà en train
de réfléchir ou petite moue de gary ça
ça veut dire qu'il a fait quelque chose
parce que gary n'avez pas l'âme ou par
hasard non c'est vrai
vraiment ce qu'eric kasparov était
phénoménale à force de commenter ses
mimiques stéphane je crois qu'on va
peut-être devenir fou oui parce qu'on
n'arrive jamais à le décrypter
on n'arrive pas à décrypter alors j'ose
à peine imaginer ce qui a dû endurer le
pauvre anatoli karpov avoir le même
adversaire pendant 15 ans ils ont joué
plus de 130 parties de quatre heures en
moyenne ça veut dire que les joueurs se
sont retrouvés plus de 700 heures l'un
en face de l'autre avec un gary kasparov
faisant des mimiques ça doit être
délicat pour la santé mentale d'un
anatoli karpov alors que nous allons
jeter un petit coup d'oeil sur etienne
bacrot le voilà etienne bacrot donc
concentré mais une position pas très
haut
pas terrible bas relief et semble serein
le voilà qui braillent f il a joué
l'ouverture très solide avec pro pas de
risque et bas reliefs
c'est un spécialiste alors que kasparov
a joué le coup j'avais les g3 donc ils
rentrent pas dans la complication il n'a
pas osé
garry kasparov villageois il faut
prendre 5 il a eu peur de la préparation
peut être il a usé une préparation de
quatre chefs peut-être surtout que ce
n'était pas bon voilà qu'il ne l'a pas
vu flamme va jouer kg si cela c'est très
probable ça y est c'est fait kg six
pattes bluff avec vladislav il met ses
pièces au bon endroit à leur public et
sont bloqués voyez du chiqué s'est
bloqué mais ça c'est normal
j'ai siégé si ça ça vient d'être
confirmée valider les deux cavaliers
montent sur les cases f4 pour katché ff5
pour kasparov
il ya une sorte de ballet cavaliers mais
ici je vous le garantis vladislav n'est
pas plus mal dans cette position il a
plutôt même une belle position stéphane
il a bien réussi son ouverture contre
gary la wii une position tendue alors
peut-être maintenant que il menace des
cinq n'ont toujours pas il peut
envisager trois des cinq dans certains
cas puisque l'option au sein qui a été
bien défendu mais en tout cas ce qu'il
faut voir c'est maintenant la tête de
kasparov
voilà il est là garry kasparov alors que
vlad toujours avec sa chaise en arrière
alors que notre ordinateur est en train
de juger la position comme égal tout à
fait jugement informatique puisque
l'opposition évidemment très complexe il
faut dire qu'avec ses joueurs
ces deux des joueurs les plus
charismatiques qui existent ils sont là
pour choisi chèque pour bien jouer aux
échecs mais aussi pour le spectacle ils
font des belles parties il faut y bouge
pas au bout voilà vladislav tkachiev
l'aïd est à fond mais vraiment à fond on
rappelle quand même que vlad a été quart
de finaliste du championnat du monde
deux parties donc cette année et il a
été éliminé par great choc quand il
ajoute le jeune nacho qui pour l'instant
que passer un sale quart d'heure dans
ces quarts de finale puisque il est en
position inférieure contre gourévitch
puisqu'il a perdu la première partie
avec le champion du monde sortant
bon ça fait beaucoup de champions du
monde y a que des bons joueurs ici à
cannes stéphane oui c'est vrai c'est
quand même très beau plateau voilà la
chaise la chaise en arrière latéral à
quatre chefs
il joue sa partie la partie de son année
au moins quand on kasparov
oui tout à fait il ne rencontre pas
souvent garry kasparov s'est peut-être
même sa première confrontation face à
gary et ça ça le chauffe etienne bacrot
champion de france 2000 sur l'écran
concentré mais bon il obtient des
chances contre bas relief mais ça sera
quand même très très difficile il faut
surtout regarder la pendule
ils sont équilibrés 18 minutes chacun
pour l'instant on n'y a ni barrière très
calme etienne bacrot un peu inquiet n'a
que 17 ans étienne et pourtant il a déjà
l'air très très fort dans sa tête
très sûr de lui kasparov a joué kasparov
a joué t4 le coût des trois des quatre
des trois des quatre ça c'est un coup
explosif 500 responsables
il veut mettre le feu au centre menace
de prendre en 5 pour libérer
complètement sans vous c3 effectivement
il a une paire de fou gary qu'il a envie
de faire jouer là nous attendons le coup
de vladislav puis on prend des quatre
vraisemblablement avec les noirs il va
prendre en t4 maintenant au niveau du
temps il reste vingt minutes à garrigue
entre 15 à vladislav diouf alors quand
même que gladys life accélère comme il
arrive de retard c'est quand même
beaucoup
stéphane on a du mal à comprendre il a
il faut rester sur cette position parce
qu'elle est quand même extrêmement
compliqué extrêmement compliqué la
position donc il faut faut bien la
regarder ici il pourrait y avoir
puis on prend déjà la fin des quatre sur
le croit on répondrait par dame prendre
des cartons mais le mans
pion prenait 4 il faut simulescu de
toute façon il est forcé stéphane il
était obligé de jouer tu reprends des
quatre pratiquement vladislav et après
dame prend des cadres de garry kasparov
et bien là il ya plusieurs possibilités
on peut jouer c'est simple le coup
dynamique on peut peut-être envisager
kode5
mais ça ça a l'air moins bons cavaliers
aux cinq facile
il est en train de bien vérifier
vladislav c'est c'est quand même très
très chaud cette position des cas de shu
par kasparov c'est le dernier coup joué
dans cette partie et la plan sur les
pièces oui un plan immobile les deux
joueurs ne bouge pas d'un cil à cil
lundi cela bouge un peu là maintenant et
que la discipline ne quitte pas la veste
le voir même le cuir mais ne quitte pas
le cuir ladislav est en cuir il a l'air
ce qui n'a pas l'air un peu fatigué il
n'a pas des cernes sous les yeux un
petit peu peut-être il a fait la fête
hier il a pris d april appréhender
quatrième l'un des quatre pions d'être
en cas d'écart au prix de la dame
d'autres événéments par la dame et les
artésiens sont pures 4 à noter que ceux
qui ont encore été attaquées si on avait
repris du fou 8 et bien ce pion 4 serait
tombé puisque le cavalier aurait pu
prendre il est attaqué trois fois le
pion aux cadres donc en prenant de
l'adar me protège le pion une fois de
plus voilà le pion est maintenant
protégé trois fois également
vous voyez trois pièces vertes qui
attaque trois pièces jaunes qui
défendent donc on ne peut pas prendre le
pion maintenant question que va jouer
vladislav évidemment c'est tout problème
l'imposition est égal alors que
l'ordinateur mentionne ces cinq avec
égalité ou camel et 17 ou dame ses huit
boucles rue dom s'est vite c'est plus
bizarres dame s'est vite on se demande
ce que la dame vient faire là mais c'est
un coup informatique je pense pas que
vladislav vanryb ladislav il préfère
mettre les pièces au bon endroit
donc je pense que ces cinq c5 mahler
la bonne option pour vlad il est
toujours terrible et volailles il bouge
il bouge il bouge quoi sur sa chaise
ladislav ouais mais kasparov aussi on
voit qu'il bouge bien la jambe kasparov
ces deux joueurs très nerveux très très
nerveux
ça changeait quand même un contraste
énorme il réservé que 12 minutes à
vladislav contre 20 minutes kasparov
ça c'est énorme ça va se jouer sur le
temps cette partie c'est beaucoup une
minute d'écart c'est beaucoup trop
oui ça serait dommage dommage comme
ladislav c'est beaucoup trop se trompent
dommage qu'il perde hommage aux hangars
et ça serait dommage quand même mais bon
attention ces défauts ne sais pas si
j'aurai terminé au talon mais c'est à
noter que si ci se fait dominer comme ça
autant en blitz
il va perdre pourquoi ben il pourra pas
réfléchir autant ambit win avec kasparov
non plus le blitz n'a tout simplement
rien à voir ses fans
oui mais en fait j'ai bien peur que si
les dominer autant en tant qu' un semi
rapide il le sera aussi en blitz
même si que s'ils oublient si on est
dominant autant au blitz et on perd la
partie un jugement qui n'engage que toi
moi je serais curieux de voir les beats
entre eux vladislav et gary mais pour
cela il faut que vlad tiennent le coup
bas relief varié f
lui il joue tranquille au je crois que
là oui ça y est la mariée fallait cédé
un seul coup etienne at c'est l'adage
n'est plus apte à jouer on a joué le
coup c 510 5 des cinq ça c'est un coup
simplificateur c'est un coup
simplificateur kasparov abri tempo en d5
ta peau ça veut dire tout de suite
semble irriter 5 ne soit pas un cottage
grâce aux grands tours tour en tour
était joué
il faut rester la casse voire au delà de
la tour la région c'est sûr renseigner
l'a fait il l'a fait et maintenant il
faut prendre des 5 avec quelque chose
stéphane mais avec quoi c'est la
question soit avec le cavalier soit avec
le foot semblerait que des 5 n'était ne
soit pas un coup très judicieux
cavaliers trempions des cinq lapins
pièces de kasparov sont toutes au mieux
deux cavaliers très fort vers le roi de
fous très fort vers le roi la tour sur
la colonne ouverte la dame centralisée
il ya une énergie potentielle de la
pièce de kasparov qui fait peur oui
c'est très risqué ce qu'a fait un plat
10 la flamme à noter que pour l'instant
l'argument de plat 19 sec son cavalier
attaque le fou et donc qu'ils risquent
de gagner la paire de fou c'est possible
c'est ça qui pose problème à garry
kasparov
voilà ce qui a été joué il acheta
gardien il ajoute l 1 il a joué autour
des 1 était jouée tourne bien il faut
que vladislav joue plus vite
ouh là là là là ça va pas du tout ça
stéphane ça va pas du tout il est très
très mal lablad islam nar non il peut
jouer ces six mauvais sombrer tg son
cavalier oui mais c'est 6 c'est ce coup
là ça tue un peu le savez ça tue le fou
et des pièces de kasparov sont super
active que je veux qu'il y ait cinq
maintenant
oh la la aïe aïe aïe
vladislav il n'est pas bien où il a joué
des cinq un coup quand même un peu trop
ambitieux peut-être des 5 c'était une
tente et rajala qui lui révèle igf 4
voilà c'est le coût que j'avais envie de
proposer comme les jets f4 aïe aïe aïe
j'ai fait alors que cabaye f5 semble
fort de laissac c'est le coût qui ennuie
qui ennuie les noirs bon c'est vrai que
c'est pas évident évident tout ça il a
peut-être 6,5 intermédiaire dans
certains cas mais les pièces de kasparov
ont l'air extrêmement bien placé mauvais
mauvais mauvais tous est présent ce
faire il aurait avalé prend 1,6 à noter
c'était fin car il prend ainsi ses lois
au fc csn cavalli prend 1,6 oui oui
échec échec c'est vrai enfin ces cinq
effectivement c'est un très bon 5 si le
coup ennuyeux c'est un coup très fort
que casper façon de jouer il lui reste à
caracas par 19 minutes il nous reste
onze à vladislav qu'avait dit le sens
que ça y est c'est fait or il est il est
horrible eleven 4 5
attention alors la menace évidemment ces
cavaliers angers7 oui qu'elle est proche
des 7 15e pions et le roi noir est
complètement dans les vaps autres
menaces qu'elle est franchie comme tu
l'as dit stéphanie prend 1,6 aussi
puisque sur une capture puis emprunte
grave à lloret damache 8 maths alors là
car qu'est ce qui se passe sur cavani
pont phu ces trois ans les femmes et
bien simplement il y à la dame et la
tour donc d'un programme
et c'est fini on est tout à fait on ne
peut pas prendre qu'est-ce qu'il a joué
il a dit n'être pas jouer sa pendule
tourne sa pendule tourne trop vite
beaucoup trop vite alors que damas six
sangles être le seul coup d'oeil de m6
semble être le seul coup faut avoir les
nerfs pour jouer d'avis parce que quand
même mon mail à damas tant vis-à-vis
avec le cil fossiles le voit pas la cie
voit pas d'un même si c'est foutu
attention vlad voit quand même peut-être
aussi bien que l'ordinateur stéphane il
faut pas il faut pas qu'en non plus et
d'un même si ce ça va ça va décrire des
affaiblissements de pions d'amel 6 oui
mais enfin si on prend la peur de fou
savoir si on prenait un peu de tout ça
peut aller non de même si c'est le bon
sens dit le voilà là ils bougent sur sa
chaise ou mais je pense qu'il a vu mais
qui n'a pas envie de le jouer il n'a pas
envie de le jouer parce que il sait que
ça va être horrible après ça va être
horrible contrecarre alala autant il
reste que neuf minutes contre dix neuf
minutes à kasparov
il se fait complètement dominé autant la
vladislav la sirène joue pas plus vite
il va perdre la partie tout simplement à
la pendule ça c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
son public a noté stéphane que la salle
est quasiment plein en tout cas le bas
de la salle qui fait mille places il
doit bien y avoir presque 700 personnes
dans ce grand auditorium de cannes et ça
il faut jouer d'un rêve si c'est le seul
coup d'appel si ces forces et peut-être
que nous pouvons profiter de cet instant
de détente pour jeter un coup d'oeil à
nos deux joyeux
spir voilà nos deux joyeuses enfin la
deuxième demi-finale etienne bacrot qui
est en passe de se faire sortir mais il
semblerait qu'il ait trouvé quelques
petite chance d' attaques contre livni
barak à ce que l'on voit ici il regagne
qui regarde l'écran il a pas l'air du
tout tendues donc avantage bas relief
sachant qu'il mène 1 0 et que si elle ne
revient pas dans cette partie des biens
qu'ils seront tout simplement éliminés
et bas relief sera qualifié on va
revenir sur kasparov votre flamme ou
kasparov s'est plaint un il s'est plaint
il regarde regarder le public alors que
vlad s'approche il s'approche d'eux car
il faut qu'ils jouent la delahaye reçu
huit minutes
là c'est le stress là c'est le cheval
reste plus que huit minutes colin dix
neuf minutes à kasparov c'est énorme la
différence de temps il a l'air très
fatigué vlad hilare très fatigué on l'a
vu sur le plan précédent
kasparov il a vu quelque chose vous me
touche la crotte mais qu'est ce qu'il a
vu qu'est ce qu'il a vu il sent il est
serein kasparov
il ya l'air serein alors que vlad va
jouer son coup il va jouer tarifs si
cela en tout cas il a le mouvement de la
main qui va prendre la dame des vite
pour l'abbé tron m6 c'est sûr oh eh oui
la chose à 9,6
c'était sûr il n'avait pas le choix
vladislav les jouets d'ahmed si c'est
fait voilà bien le problème c'est que
les blancs peuvent prendre réussissez
créer des pions doublé chez les noirs
c'est vrai job d'un problème si ce
qu'avait l'épreuve 6 fou prend m6 et
puis on prend 1,6 avec des pions doublé
de franck cavallier prendre et un
cavalier scène qui va être indélogeable
c'est vrai mais d'un autre côté si on
appris la peur de fou stéphane et bien
il y aura pas de problème pour
pouf ladislav donc c'est pas ça qui est
inquiétant ce qui est inquiétant surtout
celles ci on peut le montrer
mise à part la pendule on va montrer
cette variante dame prend 1,6 c'est
virtuel qui exportent ne l'a pas encore
fait cavaler pour m6 et maintenant
peut-être cavaliers points à 6 sur un
thème bien connu et après pions prendre
fou prend cavaliers m6 et ici il y à un
pion de plus pour garry kasparov et donc
c'est pas facile pour lui a dit stop ça
ça serait une finale difficile à tenir
et la variante al air forcé après 2006
si kasparov jo d'apprendre à me l'a fait
il a fait dire à kasparov d'un programme
il est chaud d'un grand dam on va
montrer sa et caisses ladislav reprend
avec le pion g il faut absolument
rentrer ça puisqu'il n'a pas pris comme
c'était attendu
on vous remontre les derniers coups
enerdel programme jeux par kasparov qui
en surprend moi jeunes à l'art de la
thyroïde ça évite de perdre un pur on
s'invite avait servi de perdre un pion
la menace c'est de prendre ces trois cas
sport vous devrez rapatrier le fou en d2
ça paraît logique
donc voilà pour l'instant nous en sommes
là avantage kasparov qui a eut infligé à
vladislav une faiblesse dans sa
structure de pions on voit vlad
il a l'air un peu inquiet et surtout
très fatigué où il a jeté un coup d'oeil
à kasparov
il a jeté un coup d'oeil méchant et
garry kasparov vladislav
on me signale que j'ai dit cela aurait
été vu dans un bar hier soir très tard
et des coutumiers du fait d'ailleurs oui
c'est un fait darblade cet homme fêtard
peut-être il a fêté sa qualification
hier et aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui ils
en payent le prix
ah oui mais a noté le siba kasparov et
bien et ne dormira plus avant les demi
finales puisque il ne déroulera pas mais
oui la livrade il faut tenir maintenant
contre garry kasparov ce qui te
permettra d'aller faire une sieste et
donc de te reposer pour les listes de
départage qui s'annonce très chaud s'il
y en a stéphane on joue pour un titre
quand même important oui champion du
monde deux parties rapides champion de
gronde world championne the best in the
world le meilleur joueur de la planète
en partie rapide ça c'est plutôt une
coupe du monde alors son vainqueur de la
coupe du monde c'est pas tout à fait
pareil ah oui mais le vainqueur de la
coupe du monde est considéré comme étant
le champion du monde moi et c'est vrai
c'est vrai puisqu'il n'y a pas de
championnat il n'y a qu'une coupe et
bien ça se passe comme ça alors kasparov
réfléchir ça y est kasparov prend son
temps ça fait quatre minutes qui
réfléchit dans cette position alors que
vladislav est toujours sur cette chaise
en train de bouger
c'est clair alors content il reste seize
minutes à kasparov contre 7 minutes à
vladislav tkachiev sept minutes c'est
très peu c'est pas bien qu'à sport on
peut réfléchir longtemps pour trouver le
plan question fonds général joue par
séquences stéphane c'est à dire qu'en
fait ils calculé le calcul est calculée
ensuite ils jouent trois coups tempo
c'est son truc pour faire réfléchir ses
adversaires moi je ne suis pas partisan
de cette méthode
je préfère réfléchir
après chaque coup
oui alors que là on voit les deux
joueurs très tendu kasparov est en train
de réfléchir la suite de coups qui va
asséner alors que ladislav reste
immobile debout sur sa chaise avec son
cuir qu'il n'a pas quittée ne quitte
plus son cuir le 10 nov
c'est peut-être son fétiche qui lui
aurait été offert par une admiratrice
kasparov là qui jette un oeil par les
écrans géants etienne bacrot qui joue
etienne bacrot alors j'ai la position
sous les yeux et je peux vous dire que
etienne n'est pas si mal dans cette
position n'est pas si mal c'est complexe
il peut peut-être créé la surprise
etienne bacrot ce serait vraiment une
surprise qu'il arrive en pleine contre
bas relief c'est qu'ils arrivent à le
battre avec les noirs alors que kasparov
n'a toujours pas joué
il est en train de réfléchir dans une
position curieuse à s'allier ça y est il
a fait feu qu'est ce qu'il a fait je
crois qu'il a été de l'avant foot et 4
un coût qui va de l'avant
stéphane un coup tranquille plusieurs
propositions à noter que ce coup perd la
paire de fouet ce n'est pas habituel
chez kasparov
oui parce que si ça ils peuvent venir c5
et gagnerait la paire de fou puisque le
fousseret obligé de revenir sur ces
trois soit en que 3 et dans tous les cas
le cahier des cinqueterre de reprendre
donc un choix curieux de careil et ouais
mais ça fait réfléchir vlad et ça c'est
pas bon parce que sept minutes
il reste maintenant moins de 7 minutes
et des jouets tempo vlad il a joué très
vite il a joué tous ses mythes
je chasse le cavalier f5 qui est mon
ennemi dans sa région pas mal ce coup il
va le replacer l'oeuf où il va le
remettre sur la case e6 c'est bien vu
puisque le food et 4,2 kasparov empêche
le cavalier d'y aller donc le fou sera
bien placé en haut 6 c'est bien vu de la
part de vlad d'autant plus qu' il fait
jouer sa tour c'est tombé 8 vers le pion
b2 donc aussi peut-être un coup que
kasparov n'a pas prévu c'est il est en
train de revenir vladislav est en train
de revenir
c'était extraordinaire - il joue très
précis là il est très fort il est très
fort
il est vraiment phénoménal la chaise en
arrière alors que le public a l'air
extrêmement chaud ici à cannes alors que
j'estimerai presque à marseille
l'estimation de l'ordinateur est
redescendu donc sauf c'est ce qui prouve
que le vlad a joué assez précis
peut-être kasparov un peu moins en tout
cas selon les critères de leur lit clan
terre de l'ordinateur qui sont toujours
effectivement à prendre avec des
pincettes puisque ces joueurs là sont
capables de battre l'ordinateur ça y est
les joueurs
il a joué il ya eu deux coups cavaliers
ou trois jouées par kasparov
vlad prend ce cavalier plate a pris 1,3
coup très curieux très curieux à la
reine un resort 3 est un coup curieux
puisque kasparov peut reprendre du pied
et ensuite chassé le cavaliere 4,9 laddh
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il a vu
quelque chose surprend il veut jouer fou
aussi cela dit cela c'est ça l'idée il a
prévu sa faux si c'est si le fou s'en va
il y aura là cazaux 2 voilà une des
idées de vladislav tkachiev mais est-ce
que kasparov 25e ses repères verra le
pion f6 et oui c'est un problème c'est
un problème
oh là là mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils apprirent 3 comme
ça alors que ce soir au phare prix
écoutions f
vlad est revenu avec le cavalier sur les
cases aux six sapeurs le pion f6 de
traduire le coccyx donc il y à peyrens
verdict d'un pion oui mais après il peut
jouer fou g7 peut-être et contre-attaqué
sur le point b 2 mais enfin on a du mal
à y croire dans cette position il
semblerait que kasparov as une nouvelle
victime
il a pris en abscisse saillé kasparov et
vlad a joué foucher 7 direct
fall et 7 c à l'air de tenir fou prend
fougerais par kasparov roi prend b3
voila voila il consolide son pion plus
c'est problématique là c'est très
problématique pour le dit cela il a une
position perdante
il est mal autant c'est très très
difficile
c'est très difficile kasparov est
vraiment un sport est en effet grand se
qualifier au roi m6 l'on voit en cible à
banon expo filet quand ils allaient
blanc il est vraiment très fort
l'ordinateur mentionne le coutour f1 qui
a l'air de gagner tout de suite
effectivement puisque le curve 7 est
très faible ne pourra pas être défendu
après tours f1 vladislav se retrouvent
mais pour vraiment voir s'il serait très
mal
c'est un réflexe à stefano montres leroy
en finale et c'est pas toujours très bon
il ya des réfutations tactique des
problèmes tactiques c'est le cas ici
kasparov à 13 minutes et là dedans a
plus que cinq bras il joue tour f1
kasparov
il est vraiment il rate rien jouable
narain jouable injouable complètement
elle fiable et bien nous aurons donc
garry kasparov affrontera le vainqueur
du match
de quel match et bien le vainqueur du
match courez vite contre crédoc qui sera
sans doute pour éviter 60 du corps est
vite qui a gagné la première femme verra
ça tout à l'heure on va vite et surtout
gagner la première coupe du monde alors
que etienne bacrot etienne bacrot pour
le moment est moins bien légèrement
moins bien évité par payet mais enfin
c'est encore jouable
voilà aplati cela va peut-être quelque
chose mais on a du mal à y croire
puisque là il avait passé sous la barre
des 5 minutes et ça ça ne pardonne pas
l'ordinateur affiche un avantage de plus
1 66 pour garry kasparov
ce qui équivaut donc un regain
techniques en tout cas un énorme
avantage et en finale ordinateur fait
peu d'erreurs ça se voit vladislav un
pion de moins ces pièces sont mal
coordonnés mal harmoniser ce n'est pas
dans son style c'est affreux c'est un
rêve vadis lave qui joue vladislav qui a
joué le un coup tours b 6 considéré
comme étant le plus fort par
l'ordinateur est là maintenant qu'est ce
qui se passe il ya cavaliers h4 échec
pour les matic kasparov qui adorent
mettre ses cavaliers sur les cases f5
way va sans doute réussir en ahl m ici
il va aller sur cette case aulas alliés
s'étaient réunis c'est terminé
maintenant il n'y a plus d'espoir pour
vlad kasparov réfléchi mais là il est
impitoyable dans ce genre de position
d'eric à sport pour lui c'est une pure
formalité
il n'y a aucune chance qu'il aura de ce
coup alors que le petit etienne que l'on
voit ici est en train de souffrir
il souffre etienne bacrot il a une
position pas facile donc il a
l'impératif de gagner voilà dryef vient
de proposer les changes des dames pour
aller en finale et donc pour assurer au
minimum la nul difficile pour les franco
français alors que kasparov a choqué des
quatre échecs
moi j'essaie roger cette chaude par vlad
quasiment à tempo l'aiac à audi s5 coup
très fort qui fait mal et qui a l'air
tout simplement de gagner la maison
et oui c'est fini après caliente cinq
échecs vladislav va sans doute abandonné
puisque il n'a plus aucune chance de
s'en sortir il va perdre encore un pion
voilà vous voyez ici la position des
pièces de vladislav tkachiev qui sont
orales accueilli et 5 joué par kasparov
vladislav va quand même se battre il a
joué trois ans h7 est là il ya le coup
cavaliers 17
car il y eu cette réponse est oui car la
carrière ou ses huit élections m 7 est
attaqué par la tombe et le curé vii
recueille 7 c'est le goût qui doit faire
abandonner normalement il a joué il a
joué voilà 47 qui n est encore un il
reste deux minutes à kaspar aura cassé
la menace sa menace autre chose samana
sa menace matsa manas matt ces menaces
un match grâce à la série ça y est c'est
l'abandon abandon de ladite offre quatre
chefs élimination alors que le public
applaudit le public applaudit voilà ils
se parlent ils se parlent ils se parlent
cre a indiqué qu'à ce cas de chefs et
kasparov
garry kasparov il explique que c'était
sans doute pas clair et qu'il a raté
quelque chose
éric laporte de toute façon qu'est-ce
qu'il en train de dire à vlad il est en
train de lui dire j'ai raté ça alors
qu'il a gagné la partie et qui devrait
plutôt lui tire au tour que mieux jouer
non moi je n'ai pas bien joué à tel
moment c'est son style à garry kasparov
eh oui gary
moving kasparov il est content ici il
affrontera donc le vainqueur de la
partie gourévitch chioukh très beau
match
surtout si c'est gourévitch ce que pour
vite chez champion du monde sortant ne
l'oublions pas donc nous allons passer
maintenant à la partie bacrot marais f
etienne bacrot etienne bacrot qui est en
train de jouer il joue le tout pour le
tout et etienne bacrot avec x 6
maintenant
comme nous n'avons pas la position je
crois qu'on va arrêter là où nous allons
nous quitter on vous dira sur le chat
tout de suite ce que fait etienne bacrot
et donc voilà donc je vous donne rendez
vous tout de suite sur le chat en
attendant garry kasparov qualifié
stéphane bonne nouvelle ou mauvaise
nouvelle
mais bonne nouvelle pour le spectacle
parce que si on a un match caspar
gourévitch ça va ça va voler très haut
puisque ce sera le numéro un mondial
contre le vainqueur de la précédente
coupe du monde donc ça va être explosif
tout à fait donc c'est bien pour
kasparov c'est bien pour le public mais
c'est dommage pour le public cannois
puisque ils sont fans de vladislav
tkachiev donc on vous laisse sur ces
images de bach robert f le vainqueur
donc probablement bas relief dans ce
match jouera contre le vainqueur de
adams polgar on vous donne rendez-vous
donc tout de suite sur le chat mais tout
à l'heure stéphane à 18h30 pour la
partie pour la pub pour la prochaine la
dernière partie du quart de finale avec
polgar adams merci de nous avoir suivis
[Musique]